[Music]
super fun to be back here I love living
in California you just feel healthier
when you live in the state of California
the problem is the people of Los Angeles
take the healthy living to extremes with
the cleanses and the juices and the
wheatgrass and the colonics and those
people don't stop talking about nuts up
hey Rebecca how are you good good really
good really good for the last 12 days
I've just had apples just apples and all
the maple syrup I want and I feel clear
I feel spiritually and physically clear
it sounds awful yeah you hear miracle
stories well I was just down for the
count for 12 18 24 months on the couch
and I couldn't get off the couch and I
thought this is it this is it I'm gonna
take my last breath on this couch and
then I bought a blender and now I'm back
I came back good good to know good to
know that's how I'm gonna start
answering all my questions Erin how are
you so good yeah I've got so much energy
oh my god I feel like I could flip over
a car I'm in the middle of a 45 day meat
juice cleanse and let me tell you this
the key is you get the entire animal in
the blender that's the game
the whole chicken get it in there the
lamb the wool the bonnet shove it in
there the skull of the cow whatever it
takes because the vitamins the vitamins
are in the bones people I've so much
energy alarm clock who needs an alarm
clock I get up three four hours before
the alarm goes off so excited cuz I know
I've got a frozen L pack I got a
liquefied bear winnette I've actually
had to change my entire diet around six
weeks ago after $600 in blood tests
turns out I am gluten intolerant I
thought this was a trend a fad no it
exists yeah yeah for those of you are
not familiar with gluten that is the
ingredient they put in food to make it
delicious yeah it's it's at everything
there's a list of foods I cannot have
beer bread those are the two reasons I
get out of bed in the morning crackers
cookies chips croissants pizza pasta
pancakes happiness joy kitten
[Applause]
let's review the list of foods I can
have the arrowroot buckwheat rice Garf
aza flax millet Tefft quinoa twigs bark
steel wool as I want there is a magazine
they give you when you leave the
doctor's office to help you transition
into a gluten free lifestyle the
magazine is called living without it's a
thin magazine it comes with a razor
blade the worst news ever and now that
I've been talking about on stage for
about 6 8 8 weeks now inevitably someone
will come up to me after a show and tell
me about their gluten free lifestyle
don't I'd rather take a pencil and stab
my eye out than hear about her movie
free lifestyle this woman came up to me
after show but a couple of weeks ago she
comes up to me after the show she gets
real low I don't know why pasty white
skin just frail big eyes and she's like
spent a this have been I've been gluten
free since 1986 and now yeah you got to
be careful they don't label anything
correctly it's in the sauces it's in the
salad dressings it's in the sauces so I
guess it behind me just going keep it
moving creepy lady crazy ma'am here's
the only thing in this entire process
that has made me laugh on a list of
foods I should not have because they
contain gluten communion wafers
communion wafers only break this down
I'm Catholic Conan's Catholic my mom is
a Catholic school teacher I have been
trying to get out of mass my entire life
I know I could be like I'm allergic I'm
allergic to the body of Christ
I can't sit this one out you know what
I'm saying I mean Catholic Mass is so
stressful it makes me so nervous just
one time just one time I want to walk
down the aisle and the priests to be
like body of Christ amen
quick question I just does this not go
knit it I just when it's transformed
into the body of Christ did they take
the gluten out
I'm some stomach issues which is
technically his fault
[Applause]